and the elevating Garwood Centennial
professor of English and professor of
Women's and Gender Studies at the
University of Texas Austin she's the
author of mixed feelings feminism mass
culture and Victorian sentimental
sensationalism and archives of feelings
traumas sexuality and less and public
cultures and she Co I did it with an
Pellegrini public sentiments a special
issue of the scholar and feminist online
and with Janis Tigran and Reynolds
political emotions she's been co-editor
with anne-marie jogos of glq a journal
blog and getting studies and current
writing projects focus on the current
state of LGBTQ archives and the creative
use of them by artists to create counter
archives and interventions in public
history so thank you very much for being
with that and it's gonna leave us in a
seminar style of discussion and as
opposed to a formal presentation and
I'll turn it over to you thank you the
reasons that you could lean from any
kind remarks it's very special for me to
be here since I was a Rockefeller in
1990 2000 so it's 15 years ago it feels
like a very appropriate moment for
reflection on that because I am
currently also on a fellowship at
Cornell this year so thinking about what
those fellowship years can mean and
bring to one's work and certainly the
years that I spent at Columbia was
transformative for not only
projects that I was working on then it
allowed me to really bring oral history
into my work in a way that I would
otherwise not have been able to do and
the ongoing relationship that I've had
was very Marshall and really and with
many people who come through the doors
of this program the development of the
MA program working with the September
11th 2001 project meeting a young person
and watching her grow up to become the
teacher and mentor to you that she is
now I really valued the ongoing
connections that I've built and in a way
that's so much in the spirit of oral
history because one of the things that
an oral history project enables one to
do it certainly was the case with my
work with lesbian AIDS activists
involved with act up New York and other
organizations here that punch that I had
been doing an oral history project would
allow me to build relationships with
people as one way of contributing to my
scholarly project has more than return
to the gift in that I have had ongoing
connections with people that I met
through that project and it is also
again really transformative
aspects of the work that I try to do as
a scholar and I'm also just I'm gonna
live my life I think
performing what I think of as the aim to
have conversation become research which
is another thing that I've been Bolden
to imagine as a result of my history so
how did this plans for this evening this
is this is a one-off it's a live oral
event although part of the reason for
that has to do with your topic for this
year for the series being medicine
health and oral history which is
something that I am of course very
interested in having written a book that
takes trauma as one of its main
categories and another book that takes
depression as one of its main categories
there's certainly things that I have to
say about that but because I felt that
it wasn't currently working on a project
that took up those categories I wasn't
sure that I could concoct a formal red
paper and so in my discussions back and
forth with Amy we came to the idea that
I could perhaps reflect on the work that
I had done and it's turned out to be
very generative for me to have the
opportunity to do that it is again
partly because I am germinating new
projects and so it's it's it's really
useful to get to do that so thank you
for the opportunity so indeed one of my
goals tonight is to use that process of
reflection to just underscore and tell
you a little bit about where
now with my interest in and I think it's
one that a lot of you share and is
certainly on the agenda for the lecture
series this year to think about whether
oral history as a practice could be an
alternative to medicine and one way in
which dot has come up I think part the
series is connected with the program in
narrative medicine and Rita Charan is
someone who has had the opportunity to
share the podium with us I think in some
of the summer Institute's and her work
has been very interesting to me but in
addition to thinking about oral history
as a kind of narrative medicine I would
want to amplify that to suggest that if
it is medicine of a narrative kind it it
like also the value of world history
might lie not just in its ability to
produce narrative but its ability to
produce scenes of encounter that include
a lot of performative dimensions we were
talking about this in a little session
earlier effective kinds of exchanges the
material conditions of being in a room
with one or more people and trying to
make something happen all the ways in
which your body is involved in the
process of interviewing and in which
observing what's going on
and she being all of those effective and
emotional aspects of the interview
process have always been very
interesting to me and part of how it
does its work I would say also and I
think just from even getting a little
bit of a sense from some of you in this
year's cohort of your projects that many
of you are interested in the ways in
which oral history might be an
alternative to medicine because of its
capacity to build relationships
communities it's not just about
communities of spending what some of you
are trying to document but it's also
about building alternative social
structures whether because of the
relationships you build in the
engineering process or because of what
happens to the material that you gather
after the fact so many of us I think try
to pay attention not just to collecting
the information but to try to make sure
it does some work in the world after it
has been collected so that's that's one
agenda item for the evening is to think
about that and then the other main goal
in some ways it may supersede the first
one it's certainly one of the things
that we were focusing on in our
discussion in the previous hour is what
are the ways in which we could think
about the world history alongside what
are they called in my title other kinds
of archives of feeling and particularly
I'm going to have occasion to talk
memoir as some genre or type of writing
that one might put alongside of world
history and this has also been a very
productive site of reflection for me to
get a chance to ask myself why didn't
how I did oral history for my archive
the feelings book and why and how I
practiced a certain form of memoir for
my depression but it's a conversation
that I wanted to be able to have to have
with oral history people I don't think
that quite dumbness in this way before
because as someone who is not primarily
an oral historian but whose work has
been very inspired by world history I'm
also wanting to bring to the table some
of the many other ways in which we might
document people's lives and have oral
historians thinking about the kinds of
information they gather the kinds of
archives they produce might stand
alongside of other sources
so that we can I said earlier think
towards the bigger project of what does
it mean to produce knowledge what are
our research methods and I use the term
research method in part to legitimate
what it is that we're doing as indeed
research that could function as
important knowledge in the university
but also to expand that category and to
think about our research methods and the
kinds of products that we create the
different kinds of writing or films if
you make films or conversations about
how can we how can we expand what counts
as knowledge and what counts as the
kinds of research we do to get there
especially because the sorts of
questions that I often find myself
asking don't really have very readily
answers even something like feelings
trying to get a question like the answer
in and through the legitimating force of
scholarship and disciplinary training
came up earlier is I think very
important an interesting place to type
try to do some work so those are my two
goals and I think that before I say more
because you all are involved in the
practice of world history I thought it
would be interesting and in the spirit
also of some of the work that I've been
doing around writing practice as well as
interview to do a little bit of talking
know a little bit of writing together
before I proceed
so because I'm wanting to to talk about
oral history and memoir together I
thought it would be interesting for you
to do a little talking do a little
writing and I was thinking that the
assignment would just be for you to turn
to the person next to you and say how
are you doing you know how are you
feeling that but I also was mentioning
my use of keywords as writing practice
and one of the words that earlier in our
discussion was rigor so I'm actually I'm
going to suggest that you take that as
your topic in any way shape or form and
so I'm going to invite you to find a
partner and I will tie you so that each
person gets let's say two minutes each
to say anything that comes up for you
around this word rigor
there's no right answers no wrong
answers it's just whatever comes into
your head and then we'll proceed from
there to have you just write for two or
three minutes
okay so you don't feel like you had to
cut that thought off get to grab a piece
of paper and a pen and so I'll give you
three minutes to just write in any way
through it with about the rigor go
anywhere and generally with this kind of
writing practice but I want you to
rewrite that is to keep your hand on the
page as they do if you're stuck with
Sam's duck and as you can imagine one
reason I wanted you to have the
experience of doing those exercises is
so that we might have some material to
discuss in the Q&A about the difference
between writing and speaking of
expression or revelation if I had given
me at the topic how are you feeling
there might be some obvious ways in
which you would have ideas or
experiences about one over the other one
common expectation might be that people
would share things writing for
themselves that they wouldn't share with
others on the other hand again those of
you who have done the world history
interviewing I'm sure would would be
familiar with the ways in which
sometimes people are actually able to
say things in the context of interview
or
is that even they like themselves not
have expected that they were going to
say or even knew so I don't come to that
comparison with necessarily any
preconceived ideas about which is the
more intimate form or which is the form
the suited to the work of trying to
document feelings since we didn't do
that version of the exercise I'm
actually clutch arm to think about what
the difference might be when given the
topic of a keyword like rigor so I hope
that will feed into our discussion in
some way shape or form so but let me let
me continue on with my reflections so
the first stop along the way is just to
look back at my archive of feelings but
the subtitles which is trauma sexuality
lesbian global cultures I know some of
you in the room have read some pieces
from that word your seminar
I won't presume I'm sort of presuming
that you have some familiarity project
so I often tell the story of being
brought to oral history by virtue of an
interest in the intersection of trauma
and testimony which was a very vital
site of interest
in my world of literary and cultural
studies particularly building off of
important work in Holocaust Studies and
a kind of excitement about the
possibility of testimony as alternative
archives at what people had to say about
their memories could be a very important
way of doing some work in the world
so also found trauma and testimony to be
interesting categories of what it also
called public feelings a place where
there's really in the public sphere for
people to talk about often very painful
experiences to be able to talk about how
they feel about those experiences and
for that to be meaningful in its social
and political way I think there are also
up in claims made for testimony as
having a kind of therapeutic power both
on an individual level and a collective
level is that if we share this
information a certain kind of repair
will take place we can see this in
public institutions like treatment
reconciliation commissions but this is
also where and this came up in our
earlier discussion my training in
critical theory also puts me in
sometimes named somewhat suspicious mode
with respect to the claims that are made
for those categories so I thought I just
found that to be very generative to not
necess
we presume that testimony about trauma
always a good thing but rather to look
at the circumstances under which
something like testimony is produced and
circulated and so that was where it was
so amazing and I just affection for just
her enthusiasm for acknowledged
production in her vision in creating the
Rockefeller fellowship by God which was
specifically designed for those who were
not oral historians to practice oral
history when I read the mission
statement where that fellowship I not
only felt like that was my name but it
was a good thing that she was wanting to
take the Protestant world history of it
in the hands of people to do that work
I'm trained as literary critic we read
text you know we read literature books
we often read ones that are historically
distant we are not dealing with live
people and so I found it really exciting
it also sometimes scary and overwhelming
to be in the domain of dealing with live
people and getting to ask them questions
and find out what they think about stuff
if there is that way where I'm committed
even as people we're talking about a
rigor and about the way that the kind of
academic training I have allows me to
through pull oral history into the
domain of proper research I'm often
trying to work the other way and say hey
we don't know how to talk to each other
let's try to make something of that
capacity to be able to ask questions and
sit there and listen to
take that material and try to go
somewhere with it so my project at the
time was to interview lesbian AIDS
activists about their experiences
working in the trenches of the fight
against AIDS in the 80s and 90s I came
to that also with an interest in
activist histories from other eras so
thinking so there were a lot of
interesting questions for me about
community and activism and also wanting
to preserve the memory of activism but
get into the life history in such a way
that I this was my I'm sure my desire to
my intuition that people would narrate
stories of their peak moments of
activism alongside a kind of ongoing
framework of a human life or human lives
where there would be undramatic and low
moments as well and ways that those
activist experiences might continue to
be woven into the fabric of people's
lives over time that was meaningful to
me also thinking as a kind of child in
the sixties of different shattered
dreams activism gone awry also merged
out of the crucible of all kinds of
divisive debates have been feminism
wanting there so not to be space for a
lot of different complexities to
activism the failures the heartaches the
midst
he's the Pascal and wrong to be able to
mess with those histories and not
necessarily have to tell a triumphant
tale of success hence also my you know
my interest in that the darker emotions
sadness pain trauma anger etc and part
the sensibility there that's so
important as well to the question of
health and medicine is the lesson I took
also from clear theory which has been
very generative for my academic career
of not assuming certain things to be
normal so simple premise of queer theory
is that anti permittivity and it's had a
particular power I think when applied to
questions of health and medicine illness
and an effective life to use the tools
of queer theory to deep knowledge eyes
things that have often seen as non
normative so you know there are no bad
feelings that we must judge and dismiss
we have room for everything and so for
example in the context of AIDS activism
it was important not to stigmatize LGBT
and of their lives it was important to
take seriously the experience of illness
and also survival that people were
carrying into life's very precarious and
and fraught and and to to make space for
other kinds of narratives so that for me
is at the heart of the focus
of series on health and this and have
occasion I think to talk about how that
set of conceptual tools continues to be
very generative as I think about both my
own projects and other projects it's
been a a set of tools that I think
continues to inform my intellectual life
and experience so I embarked on this
process of oral history and and there
were some hard things even as it was
also exciting one of the one of the
hardest things was what to do with the
material ones of my time gathered it so
fine to go do those you know which is a
Charlie chiming pull down or having
equipment or questions you know any
number of things I'm sure you all have
your own stories to tell about that but
it also is joking with a student of mine
who's doing the coolies now there's a
there's a way image even though oral
history is continued is considered to be
qualitative research it is also a form
of big data because you have some nice
stuff even if you do a modest number of
interviews on something like twenty to
twenty-five interviews of let's say an
average of an hour and a half to two
hours but I felt like I was swimming in
stuff and this may be partly from my
experience as a literary critic or we
could take
for one novel I even worked on Victorian
fiction so sometimes they word 900-page
novels and it was a lot of material but
there was still a beginning a middle and
some technique for being able to make
selections about what I was going to
talk about the oral history transcripts
were just ginormous and also there are
these live human beings and and I had
walked into that possible hazard
knowingly insofar as I was was intrigued
by what it would mean to be accountable
to the people that interviewed and I
wanted to do a good job of documenting
their lives and telling their stories
but I also wanted to have my opinions
because so there was that issue as well
ethics of research as I understood them
especially from really lesbian feminist
protocols which some ways raise the bar
what constitutes ethical accountability
and I wanted to just know what that was
like from from from experience as
another mode of learning so it was right
for me to find a writing form that would
do justice to all of the things that I
thought I had learned from people all of
the critical thoughts I had about that
stuff and just to write it up I somehow
found a way there's still stuff that by
I was just thinking the other day about
cutting room floor I think it must have
been because I was thinking about how he
presented that work about one of these
seminars and someone I interviewed was
present in the room and she was really
excited about the fact that I had
included in my talk some comments she
made and thought about how early
childhood medical experience with
scoliosis had informed her her
involvement in AIDS activism and in the
politics of health it was a beautiful
story that a life history approach made
possible in being able to ask an
activist where her commitments had come
from and I can't believe that that's the
final text but somewhere along the way
it felt like it was not part of the
through-line I don't know what I was
kind of having that reflection and
regret just in the past week so another
for me quite compelling thought I have
had in having the opportunity to reflect
on that world history work here in this
context of the Center for world history
is I haven't really done another world
history project on that scale since then
and it's been 15 years and if you'd
asked me 15 years ago the thought would
do another world history project I'm
sure I would have said oh yeah let's go
like the business button so I found it
interesting to ask myself why I have
that hesitation I think it does have to
do with the logistical challenges and
difficulties of dealing with the
material and
people so just want to say that very
humbly that it gives me a great deal of
respect for the amount of time and
patience and care it takes to do even
the smallest form of a history project
but I think my particular challenge also
comes from being someone who comes to
world history from the banished points
of a writer and a critic who does want
to think about what comes after so it
was always very interesting for me to
see the work of the world history
research office in building archives of
interviews without necessarily having to
think about what would happen to them
and I was you know very fortunate to be
in orbit of the research office when
September 11 2002 thousand one project
that's going on we had a lot of
transcripts I only ever ended up writing
one small piece they spent a lot of of
work thinking about those interviews
reading and discussing them with Mary
Marshall with Amy and a range of
different people who had had done
interviews and really appreciating what
might be the work of simply collecting
stuff that others would figure out how
to use but I still have that commitment
to wanting to work with the material and
you've been working with other people's
archives or transcripts has also still
been a very challenging process for me
another treatment I've tried is in
keeping with this idea of oral history
as conversation and I have written one
piece recently about doing
conversational interviews with artists
and being able to pick and choose small
moments from
those interviews to analyze with a
commitment to abroad full-on oral
history project so there are ways in
which the practice of world history
continues to inform my work in a really
literal way but I think what I realized
considering this is that there's also a
way in which my my resistance to or mine
he's just the capacity to be a custom
illogically for many people is the
biggest lessons that I've taken away
from that experience so I'm gonna turn
from that to the next project depression
a public feeling and the choice I made
there to engage in a kind of personal
narrative and memoir and I wouldn't say
that that was necessarily in reaction
against oral history if anything it was
a parallel project of saying I'm
interested in personal narrative and
interested in feelings and and you know
there are many different ways to get to
that also as you may lean from what I've
said I like the idea of using practice
to inhabit theory so maybe I have a set
of theoretical ideas about oral history
on a set of theoretical ideas about
memoir in fact both of them often
produce similar kinds of critique about
what is
evidence of a personal life or in the
arguments for it there's a lot of anti
now more stuff out there about how it's
ruining the market the literature and
it's producing this culture of spectacle
where people are confessing their
feelings and it's big business because
you know people's inner line it's the
cell and there are all kinds of there
are important critiques I don't mean to
speak of no dismissively that also
informed my you know push-pull relation
to noir along the lines of what I've
said also about testimony as a genre
some people would also see certain forms
of memoir as a kind of degradation of
the you know holier forms of testimony
as a way of trying to do some social
feeling so so memoir became another
practice that I wanted to try for myself
in order to see where all the fuss was
about in order to see what different
ways one might be able to make it work
the other reason I church and memoir in
relation to the category of depression
was because in my desire to critique the
medical model of depression which in
some ways was it again parallel to a
desire to critique medical models of
trauma as PTSD I didn't say too much
about that earlier without
another variable and factoring my desire
to think about alternatives to a medical
model of there's something wrong with
you and you need to be fixed I had very
strong feelings about the promotion of a
medical model of depression and the use
of pharmaceuticals to treat it when my
feeling was the depression was political
problem the pressure to succeed or the
ways in which people's chances for a
good life are severely compromised by
capitalist forms of social division and
hierarchy it can be cross-hatched with
other histories of violence colonialism
that that I wanted to think about
depression and social and political
terms and a lot of the available
materials with particularly popular
memoir and popular science were for the
most part invested in the medical model
if even the memoirs that were written by
doctors often were stories of I took
medication and it made me feel better
and I this was also emerging around
coming on to the market of SSRIs to
getting the prozac and followed up with
a whole cluster of drugs in that
category that produced a lot of public
debate and discussion around you know
how we found the cure we got the pill
and so I wanted to get in there and find
a way to produce an alternative account
without necessarily doing a big
scholarly critique so I wanted to see
what my own experience of what some
people might mean and the other
important variable here was telling a
story about what academia can be like
and the ways in which it can produce a
sense of stasis stuckness a sense of
life for one's work having no meaning of
questions and issues I had that we're in
my daily domains so again this is maybe
another hallmark of my work is like to
look around and see ok what is the kind
of knowledge and instead of questions on
bringing with me to my daily life and
one of the other kinds of stories I
wanted to tell that relates to our
question of rigor is that depression
might or the experience of what cult
gets called depression might not
something
just that rather than again
pathologizing or stigmatizing those
feelings we might find ways to open up
to them and to come to the world both
individually and and socially so I
engaged in a practice of trying to
trying to tell that story and all right
we can maybe talk more about this in the
Q&A because it seemed like there were a
lot of people in the world history CO or
interested in the questions about the
practice of writing but I again had a
kind of fun and also helped with trying
to write in a different way trying to
just very simply as you've done the few
three minutes of writing take a
particular story or particular memory
and meditate on it and one of the key
things I just thought I wanted to put
out there for discussion around the
pretty obvious question and generated by
my presentation what's the difference
between oral history and memoir I would
say for me that one of the things that
the memoir enabled was a kind of
pressing of the pause button in order to
meditate on particular moments of
particular memories or sometimes
particular objects this is where the
the feelings concept comes in again you
know we that I'm not sure I would have
been able to do if someone were
interviewing me about my experience or
if I were trying to write a beginning
middle end narrative so the depression
journals in my book was written more as
a set of short pieces I also found that
very enabling for my writing practice
just try to do that as opposed to
writing something longer and more
coherent so that that ravine was
valuable and also this has been another
important part of the work that I have
done other scholars and fellow travelers
particularly in the domain of their
effects studies is to focus on ordinary
feelings so I felt like the writing
practice allowed me to turn to the
ordinary or the seemingly banal or the
low-level moments and I did circulate
belatedly some of the sections for the
memoir things like a trip to the grocery
store trying to get up in the morning
you know often that is named publicly as
a symptom of depression as making it out
of it in the morning but I kind of like
to get in there without it feel like
it's you know it sounds so simple on
paper and yet to try to get inside of
the somatic and material feel of that
experience with something that
wanted to do with the writing practice
and this is where I think interesting
issue for our discussion would be how
could you take that kind of sensibility
and feed it back into the practice of
oral history that's one of the questions
I've been asking myself in thinking
about the two genres together and also
is I have a message or as part of this
cross-disciplinary or cross modal or
John or conversation we're having when I
get to come talk to the world history
people but it's always this great
two-way street work I'm so inspired by
your projects and then I'm thinking okay
what would I want you to take from me
and you know go into the field but since
I'm not going to be able to do the five
million world history projects how
efficient could do you know what how
could you take the sensibility of memoir
that kind of drilling down into
particular moments that attention to the
affective dimensions of experience
within at least some versions of memoir
that are more interesting to me less the
sort of melodramatic conversion there -
aha you know this amazing thing happened
and everything changed but a memoir
that's more attentive to the rhythms and
motions of the that thing that might
seem insignificant but in fact is worth
our attention and oral history does do
this I find when I work with transcripts
often I am looking for those those
moments that might seem relatively
low-level or insignificant but that pop
out especially if you've been in the
room and you can sometimes again sense
that a more effective level something
important there that you might easily
pass over if you were just looking at a
transcript and looking at what was so
that's one of the things I wanted to
throw out for our our discussion based
on my brief account by no means
exhausted this of what it has meant for
me to practice these two modes in
different books and then I want to throw
out a couple more things there's time
for ten minutes about where I'm I'm
thinking now about these issues one
place that I've been doing some further
reflection on the depression project
shows a sort of weirdo baxter thinking
about questions of health and medicine
is the really rich and vital work that's
going on in disability studies right now
which was really exploding as I was
writing the depression book and in a
variety of different directions among
them the rise of sometimes queer studies
I would recommend for example a book by
Alison Kafer called feminist queer crimp
that takes again that principle from
queer studies of challenging normative
notion
of health or well-being or bodily
integrity or somatic experience and
instead ask what would what is it like
to experience the world from the vantage
point of disability and what can we
learn about not just humanists but
actually non humanists or interactions
with our environments that which
humanists in contact with non-human s
with the object world and so on it's
been really important to me in that
regard is a book by queer theorist
mao-chan called anima sees that takes up
for example chemical sensitivity and
different way of experiencing the forest
boundaries between our bodies and our
environments and I think of depression
as in a sense also something like a
chemical sensitivity disorder where we
are kind of absorbing our environments
in ways that are simultaneously material
and immaterial
and in fact that attention to the
integrated relation between body and
mind or psyche which has been part of
the work that studies I think also to
present new models of this present I
think in disability studies as well as
it rethinks what it means to
and have it a body or a mind or
simultaneously and one of the other real
areas of growth in disability studies
has been thinking about cognitive and
mental disabilities alongside of
physical or somatic disabilities and
indeed challenging distinctions between
them is quite mixed up together so I do
find myself wanting to think about how
the category of disability might be
another way to think about these
questions of what it means to to live
and to live well that were have been
part of my interest in categories like
trauma and depression however critically
I want to view those categories and
include disability itself is a very
interesting health category to think
with insofar as there has been I think
the opening up of that category to no
longer just be a simple identity
category but really or a stigmatizing
category but rather to be something that
we might think of available to all of us
to learn from so now where is this is
touching down some interesting ways in
my life that
think about in terms of world history
conversation that said the unsaid and
ordinary encounters where I find myself
thinking about this is around
accommodations for students with
disabilities in universities and
classrooms where more and more students
are presenting with official status
disability status for cognitive and
mental disabilities although because of
the nature of the protocols for
disclosing or not disclosing those
disabilities often as a teacher being
handed a letter saying the student needs
additional time to complete exams or
needs consideration with regard to
attend some classes etc I don't know
what that disability is because they do
not and it only makes sense why there
would be the need for confidentiality or
to you know to protect students around
what they feel comfortable disclosing or
not disclosing but I think that also
creates some interesting dilemmas for
how to really grapple with the issue and
also my concern building off of my
critique of the medical model in the
depression book is that students are
being given and also taking up diagnosis
in ways that don't really address the
sources of their suffering in for
example that very academic
additions themselves that they are
trying to gain access to so the
challenge of really accommodating those
disabilities goes so much far beyond
just an extension on a paper deadline or
you know not taking class I think we
have a real problem and I really want to
think about where and how the category
of disability helps and then also
possibly obscures some of those at stake
there and some of that comes from the
kind of knowledge I get through
conversations with students when they
are willing to save more than the letter
of the law ask them to stay but it's a
kind of anecdotal knowledge of how it is
that people negotiate institutions that
I'm not quite sure what to do with I but
I have thought oh if I really want to
press this would I do interviews because
this is a place where I am definitely at
odds with some of the prevailing ways in
which people understand their identity
so it is a place where I can imagine a
quite productive form of some kind of
world history where I would want to put
aside the more polemical subjective
voice that I was able to use in the
depression before I was just speaking
for myself and I wasn't presuming to
have to judge other people's narratives
in this instance my part of myself
thinking whom I probably need to pause
and think about where other people are
taking up these categories perhaps
I would and be able to perhaps have some
exchange or encounter around that so
that's one way in which I would say I'm
by no means done with world history
I can imagine places right we want to do
a kind of interview to continue to think
about these tough problems of health and
medicine and the depolarization of what
gets me but I also want to just end with
the question of anecdotal knowledge or
these through ordinary encounters as
another place where we learn something
like what we also learned at perform
through oral history and memoir and I
continue as someone interested in the
practice of writing to also wrestle with
the question that I said I wrestled with
in particular in China martial a whole
bunch of interview material into some
piece of writing I continue to think
about this is why I'm working on
archives now to how do we take our
materials and put them into some kind of
form and since I'm the writer that's my
form since I am some version of my hat's
a literary critic to literature and yet
still in many ways able to claim the
category so I have been thinking a lot
about creative nonfiction
and other forms of experimental writing
as a way that certain kinds of
conversations or oral knowledge might be
transmitted or not and as an example of
how complicated this is I wanted to
share with you a couple of pages from
Claudia Rankine's citizen and American
lyric which just came out this year and
has already been nominated for a number
of awards I was particularly interested
in the fact that she was doubly
nominated I believe this is the first
time this has happened in the categories
of birth of poetry and his criticism for
the National Book Critics Circle awards
and she's being heralded in some
versions of the press or buzz around
this book as someone who has managed to
find a way to document I'm just going to
call it I'm gonna say document moments
of what I would call ordinary racism
which is a category or a term I also use
in my book the term micro aggression is
being used a lot and not crazy about
that term because I think it also tends
to you know put a diagnostic on
something that is quite diverse and
mobile and in need of the kind of
particularity of storytelling that
someone who's trained as a poet and has
a very acute sensitivity to language
manages to put into play I'm not gonna
this is just a couple of I'm sorry it's
so randomly selected please go buy the
whole book it's but it's quite
interesting Lee laid out and it has a
lot of interesting visuals which is
another thing I'm interested in is how
but I'll just read a few opening certain
moments send adrenaline to the heart dry
up the tongue and clog the lungs like
thunder they drown you in sound know
like like lightning they strike you
across the larynx cough after it
happened I was at a loss for words
haven't you said this yourself haven't
you said this to a close friend too
early in your friendship when distracted
would call you by the name of her black
housekeeper you assumed you two were the
only black people in her life eventually
she stopped doing this although she
never acknowledged her slippage and you
never called her on it why not and yet
you don't forget if this were a domestic
tragedy and it might well be this would
be your fatal flaw your memory vessel of
your feelings do you feel hurt because
it's to all black people at the same
moment or because you are being confused
with another after being so close to
this other so the literary critic
couldn't he wants to talk about a lot of
different stuff going on here that oral
historian in me is gonna pause over a
few things but what is the use of the
view the second person as a way I think
of not using the
memoir but being able to allow
experience to float in this kind of
inter subjective space that could
involve the self could involve a kind of
dissociation from this self because I
think we sometimes used to you when we
what we mean I but we don't really want
to inhabit that body that's having that
experience but in that process of
splitting the self one also multiplies
it proliferate this up and brings it in
contact with a a third person or another
so that you could be a kind of
invitation to join in the process of
that experience she's also so attuned to
she's not just telling the story of
these incidents I feel like she is
mapping the the impact of those stories
on the body so the opening with certain
moments sent adrenaline to the heart dry
out the time of clogged the lungs so the
way that the way that a kind of
listening or taking in certain words
happens at a somatic level is for me
really important as this constant
challenge to the work of oral history is
not just discursive language or
conversation but as something that
happens at a somatic level and her
attention to things that get said that
shouldn't be said things that get not
said that maybe should be said the this
process of and never called her on it
why not and yet you don't forget so how
is it that things inhabit a space of the
onset and yet linger on in a memory that
is in her view a kind of archive of
feelings I think it
she talks about a kind of storage
container in which these things reside
at was it inside of the self is I think
a very interesting model for the
complexity of the relation between the
spoke and the unspoken and a lived
experience that happens in places other
than just words the next one a lot to
stay here
I may just have you I don't think
there's time for me to read the whole
thing out loud but she has a really
interesting way of setting talking and
driving together that's another way of
thinking about conversation is something
that happens in space where this other
activity is happening and then she
talked about having to listen to this in
a moment of ordinary racism a friend or
companion who says his Dean is making
him hire a person of color when there
are so many great writers out there
someone who lives in the Academy I I've
had to be witness to me like this
including as a white person so one of
the things that's also interesting for
me about Rankine's work is what it means
for me to be privy to these anecdotes
and to have to live it also in the
presence I'll be it in a very specific
way of ordinary forms of racism that
pervade all of their all of our lives
this was one of the things I was trying
to find a language for in my depression
book it continues to be a struggle for
me that informs this work of
documentation and it's been the way that
she closes again with the medical model
of John Henry lism
a medical term for people exposed to
stress is stemming from racism and her
desire to sit in silence in order to
buck the trend
she says you fear the night is being
locked in and coded on a cellular level
and want time to function as a power
wash just that set of images for what it
means to take certain things in to try
to sit with them and to try to process
them in some way what would be the mode
of speaking that could accomplish that
were of here what she describes as a
kind of silence and having to take pause
I think this gets at different forms of
everyday experience that are very
important to me to document and try to
find a set of genres that would be up to
that task is I think very difficult and
so I wanted to just put on the table
this question of writing in alternative
forms this goes far beyond memoir and
I'm very interested in a research and
writing practice that is bux it the
prevailing notions of rigor sometimes by
using the first person or the subjective
voice but I think there's many other
ways in which one could find alternative
writing practices that would do some of
this work and that again is this broader
context or set of methodological and
and knowledge building problems that I
would want you all to perhaps think of
your oral history work in the context of
and again to think okay it's a big
question I'm asking but you know what
what can't world history do within this
broader context of what I'm calling
archival media for being able to
document both
experience in order to stay you know how
we are living in the present and how to
survive and also change